.
[APPLAUSE]
>> HAPPY FRIDAY,.
EVERYBODY.
YOU LOOK FANTASTIC.  THERE I GO
TALKING TO MYSELF AGAIN.
SO THEY'RE MAKING ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE SCREAM MOVIES AND GET
THIS, THEY'RE MOVING THE SETTING
TO NEW YORK CITY.
WE ENT TO BRIAN KILLMEAD FOR
COMMENT.
SOMETHING CLEARLY IS WRONG WITH
HIM.
I MEAN OTHER THAN HIS
PERSONALITY, LOOKS, AND CAREER
CHOICE.
ACCORDING TO ONE CAST MEMBER,
SETTING THE MOVIE IN THIS CITY
WILL MAKE IT 20 TIMES MORE
MORTIFYING,.
YEAH, NO [BLEEP].  ALL YOU GOTTA
DO IS TUSH THE DAMN CAMERA ON
AND POINT IT DOWN ANY STREET.
IF THERE ISN'T ABASHING FOX NEWS
CHRISTMAS TREE EN YOUR WAY, JUST
HOPE THAT SOMEONE DOESN'T BEAT
YOU SENSELESS AND STEAL YOUR
CAMERA BEFORE YOU'RE DONE.
SO HOW IS NEW YORK LATELY?
YOU GOT MACHETE ATTACKS, YOU GOT
GANGS ON DIRT BIKES ROBBING
PEOPLE IN DAYLIGHT, YOU GOT
STRUNG OUT HOMELESS, AND THAT'S
JUST IN KAT'S APARTMENT.
YOU GOT SICK SOS SHOVING PEOPLE
IN FRONT OF TRAINS, TRANSIENTS
CLOBBERING THE ELDERLY, JESSE
WATERS HANGING T ON SIXTH AVENUE
HOPING YOU'LL RECOGNIZE HIM.
DON'T GIVE HIM MONEY OR HE'LL
GIVE YOU A COPY OF HIS BOOK.
DISGUSTING.  DO YOU RELOANED TO
SET A HORROR MOVIE IN FEW YORK
CITY, EX PESCE SCREAM?
IT'S ALREADY HERE.
CHECK OUT THIS TIP.
A ROBBERY THAT TOOK PLACE IN NEW
YORK CITY YESTERDAY.
WHILE THE ROBBER'S THERE,
THEY'RE WEARING SCREAM MASKS AS
THEY ROB THE PLACE.
SO I GUESS THE GOOD NEWS IS THE
PRODUCTION TEAM WON'T NEED A
COSTUME DEPARTMENT.
YOU KNOW THIS HAS TO BE A
PROBLEM FOR THE FILMMAKERS.
HOW CAN THEY TOP REALITY?
HOW DO YOU MAKE A MOVIE SET EN
NEW YORK THAT SCARIER THAN THE
SETTING ITSELF?
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE OPENING A
DOMINO'S IN ROME.
PRETTY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
IT'S LIKE TRYING TO MAKE A HEART
ATTACK SCARIER BY SAYING BOO.
IT'S LIKE TRYING TO MAKE A
HORROR FLICK ABOUT JOY BAYHEAR'S
SEX LIFE.
MY POINT IS IT'S SCARIER IN REAL
LIFE.
A HORROR MOVIE SHOULDN'T HAVE
HORROR AT THE START.
YOU HAVE TO BUILD P TO THAT;
RIGHT?
NEW YORK CITY IS HORRIBLE FROM
START TO FINISH, WHICH IS ALSO
THE REVIEW FROM THE EMMY AWARDS.
SO THEY'RE SAYING THAT THIS
INSTALLATION WILL FOLLOW FOUR
SURVIVORS AS THEY START A NEW
CHAPTER IN THE GRIM APPLE.
THEY'RE CALLING IT THE BLOODIEST
SCREAM YET.
IT WAS EITHER THAT OR DO THE
THING SAN FRANCISCO WHERE IT
WOULD BE THE POOPIEST SCREAM
YET.
I WOULD HAVE SAID [BLEEP] BUT I
WAS TRYING TO EDIT MYSELF.
I LIVE NEW YORK CITY, I DON'T
NEED A HORROR MOVIE, I HAVE THE
SUBWAY STATION.  I DON'T RIDE
IT, BUT I SOMETIMES PEE THERE.
AND IT'S GETTING DANGEROUS.
AT TIMES I HAVE REAL LIFE
ZOMBIES ON MY STREET MANIC
AGITATED ANGRY AND THOSE ARE
JUST ALL THE EMPLOYEES CNN JUST
LET GO.
CITIZENS ARE AT THE MERCY F
HUMANS WHO EXIST INDEPENDENT OF
LAWS AND CIVILITY.
REMEMBER THOSE CLASSIC PHOTOS OF
THE GREAT DEPRESSION WE SAW?  WE
NEVER THOUGHT THAT WOULD HAPPEN
GIBB, EXCEPT IT'S HERE AND WE
HAVE THE VISUAL, AND IT'S WORSE
BECAUSE LIKE KAT'S HAIR
EXTENSIONS, IT'S SELF-INFLICTED.
I GUESS THE STREETS BECAME SO
STATE THAT WE FORGOT WHY.
PROGRESSIVE POLITICIANS DECIDED
THAT WAY THINGS WORK WAS NO
LONGER NECESSARY SO THEY THREW
THE LAWS AWAY AND NOW WE'RE FREE
FALLING INTO AN AMBIVALENT ABYSS
THAT'S DEEPER AND DARKER THAN
MICHAEL MOORE'S BELLY BUTTON.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
WE GOT A FULL FINGER IN THERE.
>> LITERALLY.
>> AND HE'LL PAY FOR IT.
THOSE PEOPLE ON THE STREETS, OF
THE DEPRESSION, THEY WERE DAD
AND BROTHERS, WAR VETERANS,
TODAY MAYBE IT'S A TYNE A
PORTION OF THAT, BAT NO.
THESE AREN'T POOCK PEOPLE LOOK
FOR A JOB.
EMPLOYEE AREN'T LOOKING FOR
PEOPLE WHO SPIT ON A STAIRWELL.
PEOPLE LIKE HORROR MOVIES.
IT'S ESCAPEST ENTERTAINMENT.
YOU WANT A REALLY SCARE Y MOVIE?
HOW ABOUT THIS ONE SMITH.
SCARIER THAN ANYTHING HOLLYWOOD
PUSS OUT.
DOORBELL VIDEO OF A WOMAN BEING
ATTACKED BY THREE MEN ON THE
CHICAGO STREET AND IT WAS TURNED
INTO A CAMPAIGN AD MADE BAY A
CONSERVATIVE SUPERPAC.
HERE'S JUST A TINY BIT OF IT.
NOW THAT A HORROR MOVIE.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THERE WAS
NOBODY THERE TO YELL CUT TO END
THE SCENE.
IT'S UPSETTING ALL THE PEOPLE
YOU'D EXPECT.
THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS FOR
EXAMPLE DON'T LEAK IT WHEN YOU
SHOW THEM THE RESULT OF THEIR
DISASTROUS IDEAS.
IN PACK THEY'RE MORE UPSET ABOUT
THE VIDEO THAN THE CRIME
ITSELFISM.
MAYBE THEY'LL TAY TO SENSOR IT
AND CALL THE MAKERS TERRORISTS
AND WHY?
BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU POINT OUT
CRIME, YOU'RE POINTING OUT HOW
THESE [BLEEP] HAVE FAILED YOU.
AND THEY, THAT THEY HAVE NO
SOLUTIONS OTHER THAN HIRING
THEIR OWN PRIVATE SECURITY.
THEY'LL MAKE A FEDERAL CASE OVER
PRONOUNS WHILE DROPPING
ATTEMPTED MURDER CASES TO
MISDEMEANORS.
THE GOVERNOR CALLED THE AD
DISGUSTING, AND WHY?  BECAUSE
IT'S REAL AND POLITICIANS LIKE
HIM, AREN'T.
THEY PREFER RHETORIC, SYMBOLISM
AND EMPTY PHRASES LIKE THE SOUL
OF AMERICA, THE BIG LIE, THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY, AND MY FAVORITE,
DOG-FACED PONY SOLDIER.
BUT THAT VIDEO IS REALITY AND
IT'S TIME REALITY TOOK THE WHEEL
FROM THE FANT SSES WHO THINK THE
REAL DANGERS ARE MOMS AT SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS OAR TRUCKERS IN
RED HATS.
OF COURSE LEFT WING GROUPS CLAIM
THE AD USES VICTIMS AS POLITICAL
PAWNS BECAUSE IT'S NOT LIKE THEY
DID THAT WITH JORGE FLOYD OAR
MEEKAL BROWN.
DEMOCRATS EXPLOIT MORE 6EMS THAN
PERSONAL INJURY LAWYERS.
SORRY, EMILY.
REMEMBER THE LINE NEVER LET A
CRISIS GO TO WASTE?
IT WAS SAID BY RAHM EMANUEL, AND
LATER NANCY PELOSI'S PLASTIC
SURGEON.
ONLY LIBERALS CAN EXPLOIT A
CRISIS SINCE THEY'RE THE ONES
CREATING THEM.
SO YEAH, THAT AD, WHICH WAS
PLAYED DURING A BEARS GAME, IT
SHOCKED VIEWERS, BUT THAT'S THE
POINT.
MAYBE YOU'LL PAY ATTENTION TO
CRIME IF IT SHOWS UP IN YOUR
LIVING ROOM.
[APPLAUSE]
WELCOME, TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE MAKES MORE GREAT POINTS THAN
OUTNUMBERED COHOST EMILY
COMPAGNO.
HER GUNS ARE REGISTERED AS
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT COMPANIONS,
DOT COM EDITOR AND HOST OF
LUXURY HUNTING LODGES OF
AMERICA, KATIE PAVLICH.
SHE'S LIKE A HAY STACK, BLOND,
DRY, 161 KNOWS THERE'S A NEEDLE
IN THERE SOMEWHERE.  FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, KAT TIMPF.
AND HIS CHILDREN NEED A LADDER
TO SIT ON HIS LAP.  MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK IN THE CHAMPION, TYRUS.
EMILY, ARE YOU IN THE MOOD FOR A
HORROR MOVIE SET IN NEW YORK
CITY?
>> I'M ALWAYS IN THE MOOD FOR A
FICTIONAL HORROR STORY.
AND I'VE NEVER BENN EN THE MOOD
FOR WHAT HAPPENS ON A DAILY
BASIS HERE.
IT IS FRIGHTENING.
YOU KNOW THAT JUST I WANT TO SAY
YESTERDAY THAT SAME BODEGA WHERE
THE BODEGA OBER HAD TO MURDER
SOMEONE IN SELF DEFENSE AND THEN
IT TOOK LEAK THE GLOBAL LOBBYING
TO GET DA BRAD TO DROP THE
MURDER CHARGES, IT WAS.
>> REALLY.
>> VIOLENTLY.
THERE IS NO END EN SIGHT.
THE IRONY IS THAT WE HAVE TO
BLUR HALF THE REAL VIDEOS WE PUT
ON OUR NETWORK.
I'M SURE EVERY BET OF SCREAM
COULD BE ON EVERY BELLBOARD AND
EVERYTHING BECAUSE ES.
ALL FICTIONAL AND FAKE.
HERE WHAT THE FOUR VICTIMS ARE
FOUR YOUNG WHITE KIDS LIVING IN
UPPER SUBURBIA, WHATEVER, HEAR
THE VICTIMS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY ELDERLY AND
ASIAN, AND AFRICAN AMERICAN, AND
THAT'S NOT SEEN BEING IN ANY WAY
AMPLIFIED.
JUST QUICK FINAL POINT, I LOVE
ON THIS INSTAGRAM ACCOUNTS THAT
SAY WHY NEW YORK IS SO AWESOME,
THIS WEEK THEY HAD THE POOR
FEDEX DRIVER DROPPED ALL OF HIS
BOXES AND ALL OF THESE NEW
YORKERS WERE SURROUNDING AND
HELPING, WHERE THE [BLEEP] IS
EVERYONE WHEN PEOPLE ARE GETTING
STABBED TO DEATH?
INSTEAD THEY'RE JUST WHIPPING
OUT THEIR PHONES AND RUNNING
AWAY.
THIS CITY IS AN ABSOLUTE
SESSPOOL.
>> THERE YOU GOEM.
I.
I HOPE YOU PARKED VERY CLOSE TO
THE STUDIO.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> TYRUS: LEAVE IN GROUPS.
>> IT'S ALWAYS THE REACTION WHEN
YOU SHOW REALITY.
THAT AD COMES OUT, WE'RE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT IT LATER WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN WHAT'S THE ISLAND?
>> MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> THEY SEND THE MIGRANTS THERE
50 MIGRANT THEY FREAK OUT THEY
SHOW AN AD OF AUTHENTIC VIOLENCE
AND THEY FREAK OUT.
>> I'M STILL CLIMBING OUT OF
MICHAEL MOORE'S BELLY BUTTON.
YOU THOUGHT THAT WAS SCARY, THAT
WAS REALLY SCARY.
IT REALLY IS.
YOU SURVIVE THAT, YOU SURVIVE
EVERYTHING.
NO, THE CRIME ISSUE, THEY JUST
DID A REALITY SHOW.
FILM WHAT'S GOING ON EVERY
SENGAL DAY IN NEW YORK CITY AS
YOU MENTIONED.
MY QUESTION IS WHERE DOES IT
END?
BECAUSE THE FURTHER AND FURTHER
THEY ALLOW THIS TO GET OUT OF
CONTROL, THE MORE HARSH THE
REACTION HAS TO BE.
>> YEAH.
>> WHEN THEY ARE NOT EVEN
WELLING TO ACCEPT VIDEOS OF REAL
VICTIMS SCREAMING WOMEN IN THE
STREET ARE GETTING ATTACKED
OUTSIDE OF THEIR HOME, IT'S MORE
CLEAR THAN ERB THEY'RE ON THE
SIDE OFFULS CRIMINALS.
THE WOMAN GETTING ATTACKED BY
THREE MEN, HE THINKS THAT THE
CRIMINALS ARE THE VICTIMS.
I MEAN, WHERE DOES THAT END?
AND THEY LET ALL OF THESE
CRIMINALS OUT OF PRISON WHICH
MEANS EVEN MORE VICTIMS.
>> YOU GAVE ME THE BEST IDEA FOR
A REALITY SHOW.
IMAGINE IT'S LIKE THE BACHELOR
OR BACHELORETTE, RIGHT?
AND THE BACHELOR BACHELORETTE IS
ACTUALLY THE CRIMINAL AND YOU
HAVE TO AUDITION TO BE THE
VICTIM.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE BEST
IDEA.
>> OH, SHOULD IT BE REVERSED
WHERE THE VICTIM GET TO CHOOSE
THE VICTIMIZER?
>> I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
LEGAL ISSUES HERE.
>> WELL, YOU ARE A LAWYER.
I IF GAR OUTSHONE, EVERYONE
ALWAYS FORGETS THAT.
>> SO, YOU FEEL LIKE A SUBWAY
RIDE IS PROBABLY MORE
FRIGHTENING, KAT, THAN ANY
SCREAM MOVIE?
>> WELL, I, BECAUSE IT COULD
HAPPEN AND NO WASHINGTON D.C.
CARE.
ONE OF THE FIRST.
AND NO ONE WOULD WEAR CARE.
IF YOU DON'T WANT ANYONE TO SEE
YOU CRY, DO IT OPENLY ON THE
SUBWAY.
PEOPLE PUSH PAST YOU, NOBODY
WOULD CARE IF THAT HAPPENED HERE
NOBODY WOULD NOTICE BECAUSE
WE'RE USED TO SEEING CRAZY STUFF
EVERY DAY.
IF ANYONE DID NOTICE THEY'DBY
LIKE LOOK T THIS COOL ART
INSTALLATION.
CAN I GET A COOL PICTURE WITH
THIS?
OR LIKE YOU SAID JUST FILM IT
WITH THEIR PHONE.
I THINK THIS COULD HAPPEN OUT ON
THE STREETS AND PEOPLE WOULD
JUST BE LIKE I'M LATE TO WORK.
WHICH I AM CONCERNED ABOUT.
IS THIS GOING TO MAKE TRAFFIC
WERE WORSE?
>> IT MIGHT.
>> I HATE TO MAKE IT ABOUT ME,
BUT --
>> YOU GAVE ME ANOTHER IDEA
WHICH IS WHEN I GET STOPPED FOR
PUBLIC URINATION PERFORMANCE ART
THE INSTALLATION.
>> YES.
>> IT'S A STATEMENT ON THE FILTH
OF NEW YORK CITY.
>> YOU COULD PROBABLY PEE INSIDE
THE MOMA.
>> MEEKAL MOORE.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THERE'S A NAME FOR THAT.
DO YOU HAVE A HARD TIME WATCHING
VIOLENT MOVIES NOW?
>> NO.
I'M USUALLY A FOOT AND A HALF
TALLER THAN THE CRIMINAL.
WHEN I'M IN THEM, I'M USUALLY
KILLED FIRST.
THEY'RE GOING TO DROP THE BALL
ON IT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A WOKE
MOVIE, THE KILLER IS GOING TO BE
AN OLE WHITE MAN, YOU GUYS KNOW,
AND THE HEROS ARE GOING TO BE
WHOEVER'S THE FLAVOR OF THE
MONTH.
SO, UM, I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS IN A GROUP ONE OF YOUR
WEIRD MOVIE GROUP TEXTS YOU GOT
INVOLVE EN IT TOO, WHERE WE YOU
ARE RIGHT IN THE PLOT OF WHO'S
GOING TO GO ANDEN THE WAY TO
WORK GUTFELD'S THE BAD GUY.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT THE SCREAM FRANCHISE,
WHEN'S THE LAST, I THINK WE ALL
STOPPED AT TWOEM, RIGHT?
WHAT IS THIS, LINGERING 47?
>> I THINK THIS IS SIX.
I THINK NEV CAMPBELL IS 70 NOW.,
RIGHT?
>> I MEAN, THIS IS HOW TONE DEAF
THEY ARE.
IT'S GOING TO BE SO MUCH SCARIER
BECAUSE IT'S IN NEW YORK.
THE FOLLOW-UP QUESTION SHOULD
HAVE BEEN AND WHY IS THAT?
>> EXACTLY.
>> SO AGAIN, IT WON'T FIX
PROBLEMS, BUT THEY'LL MAKE A
MOVIE ABOUT IT.
>> I'M SO HAPPY THAT OUR
SUFFERING IS GOING TO HELP THEM
MAKE A SCARY MOVIE.
>> BECAUSE EVERYONE IN NEW YORK
IS GOING TO SAY THAT ACTUALLY A
BETTER WAY TO GO.
>> QUICKER.
>> IT'S QUICK.
>> I'M SURE THEY'RE JUSTER DOING
IT FOR THE TAX BREAK.
>> YEAH.
AND IT'S A BIG DEAL.
THEY'RE GETTING SOMETHING OUT OF
THIS.
BUT, UH, IT'S JUST MAYBE IT'S
ALSO SAFER THAN L.A., I DON'T
KNOW.
>> THEY CAN'T FILM IN GEORGIA
BECAUSE THE LAWS ARE SO
RESTRICTIVE THERE.
THEY HAVE TO FILM IN NEW YORK
WHERE EVERYONE GETS SLAUGHTERED
ON A DAILY BASIS BECAUSE THAT'S
SOME HOW BETTER.
>> I STILL LIKE THE REALITY SHOW
IDEA.
>> MAYBE YOU SHOULD COMBINE IT
WITH YOUR PEEING THING.
>> YEAH, LEAK --
>> IT WILL BE THE PROPRIETORS OF
BUSINESSES THAT GET TO AUDITION
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO PEE.
GET YOUR LEMONADE HERE.
>> I KNOW IT'S PROBABLY OBVIOUS
BUT IT WOULD BE CALLED URINE
LUCK.
I DIDN'T EVEN